it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases there's a lot of them
so let's get moving first up is the
ninth major installment in the
Assassin's Creed series it's syndicate
Assassin's Creed syndicate marks the
first time in the series where the
player can freely switch between two
different protagonists there's Jacob
Frye who's more of a hot-headed brawler
he specializes in close combat and then
there's his twin sister evie who's
strong in health and relies on her
intelligence and wit there's also a rope
launcher for even faster traversal
throughout the buildings of London hang
out with Charles Dickens and Charles
Darwin room 23rd next up is the upcoming
action adventure game in Nintendo's The
Legend of Zelda it's tri Force heroes
but this is a Zelda game you're used to
this is a co-op action adventure game in
which three players play three different
colors of series of link and they joined
forces to fight enemies and solve
puzzles you can also send cool little
emojis to help convey emotions like
thanks or over there idiot work together
with your friends on the twenty-third
tales of zestiria revolves around sori
who wishes to return peace to the land
setting out on a quest to become a
shepherd gain the power to calm the
Hellion and defeat their mysterious
leader to save both humanity and the
Seraphim but negative emotions lead to
malevolence so you gotta keep people's
feelings in check or just kill them
that's what I would do save the Seraphim
on the 20th I'm going to quickly burn
through a few games just so there's no
spoilers tales from the borderlands
episode 5 the vault of the traveler
that's out on the 20th and life is
strange episode 5 it's called polarized
that's out on the 20th there's also
another just dance there's no spoilers
it's just it's the same game so you
don't need to see it that's out on the
20th want a creepy game to play for
Halloween but you only got a wii u well
fatal frame maiden of black water just
made its way to America and Europe this
week so you can play photographer to
black waters hottest dead models oh yeah
you wanna be a star don't ya the ghosts
hurt you if they touch you but you can
use your antique camera to keep them at
bay blue steel it on the twenty-second
now I've already told you about a lot of
games is a big episode but I
fuse to not tell you about Sword Coast
legends because they played it last week
and I loved it if you ever want to play
D&D with your buddies but you live way
too far away from each other this is a
great game or you guys can play together
and dungeon crawl and one of you guys is
actually the dungeon master while you're
playing that means he can change the
dungeon in real time and talk to you
guys and make fun of you while he's
doing it and then you can roll dice to
see who is able to gallantly leap over
the rock pile or trips and Falls and
look silly it's awesome to visualize
your adventure so if you're a fan of D&D
this is for you become chaotic evil on
the 20th finally we get Guitar Hero live
which you wouldn't remember from
previous guitar heroes because nothing's
the same guitar is two by three grid and
the game plays all done with real life
footage of concerts they'll love you or
boo you based on your performance as if
playing at a party with a bunch of
friends wasn't intimidating enough
there's a bunch of new songs you can
check out but if you're anything like me
you're gonna spend most your time with
Cowboys from Hell by Pantera anyway so
let's just focus on that that's out on
the 20th for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and they're subject to
change happy gaming
oh wow